so today we're gonna have you try to do
cursive writing I have it good but it
takes forever I will rather like people
jump in the cage with anacondas for an
hour I'm worried that I might not
remember the capital letters capital
letters aren't you supposed to do it
like all in one I'm not doing that yeah
[Music]
their agent really I don't know the
letters of closes now I'm just thinking
like Bob Levitz this is probably a level
one it was pretty easy it looks likely a
little bit naughty I think I love foxes
give me motivation this area looks
pretty bad sit like that I'm just gonna
try to make fancy print okay here's my
results
it's like a little like it's like
someone shakes you stop making clothes
ooh I love pizza oh it's totally the
opposite but pretty okay that one was
definitely bad yes my results I supposed
to be capital and I should probably add
a sad face no I think it's a waste of
time in school like when you're writing
a letter to the President or someone
like that they would probably prefer a
cursive so I think it's really important
for you teachers to teach your kids how
to do cursive I'm still gonna just use
my normal hand ready I don't want to use
cursive in the future ever again